so we have this tweet from Rick Scott he
said I'm warning socialists and
Communists not to travel to Florida they
are not welcome in the Sunshine State
I'm going to play the clip for you
hey Senator Rick Scott here let me give
you a a travel warning if you're a
Socialist Communist somebody that
believes in big government I would think
twice think twice if you're thinking
about taking a vacation or moving to
Florida we're in the free seat of
Florida we actually don't believe in
socialism we actually know people and we
some people actually lived under it we
know people lived in our socialism is
not good it's not good for anybody so if
you're thinking about it if you think
about coming to Florida and your social
communist think twice we like Freedom
Liberty capitalism things like that say
it Civil War
I I am kidding by the way yeah but a lot
of people were tweeting about tweeting
about it and tweeting at me yeah they're
freaking out what I can't go to the
place that I'm constantly claiming is
the worst part of America no you can't
you should be happy there is something
about people and he's just telling you
you won't like it no no you can't I'm
fine with them thinking they can't
there's a there's definitely an aspect
of taking things for granted in the
modern age that I don't think a lot of
people understand that if they trash
this country what kind of lockdown could
actually like what what could be lost by
the way the ability to walk around
freely and stuff like that do you think
that like if if Gavin Newsom or some
governor of a left-wing State went no
fascists are welcome here that people
will be going well he's excluding People
based on their politics so what about
tolerance what's happening what happened
to tolerance man I got to balance if if
Gavin Newsom made a video and he said
Fashions are welcome in California I'd
be like okay I'd be like how did you get
elected right but like my view is like
that doesn't apply to any any of us
right it's just a term that means bad
guy yeah so it's like hey whatever but
when when they when he said socials and
Kanye's aren't welcome leftists
legitimately got mad they were like how
dare you you're like why not yeah why
can't it what is this we make everywhere
we go better I saw I think it was a
tweet from Michael malison he was just
he said something about like the the
fracturing of the of the states is going
as planned or something like that I
should actually pull that one up try and
find it but yeah I mean I don't take it
seriously to be completely honest
but I do think that when you look at the
election in Florida when you look at
here's here's what Michael Mouse said
our nation's growing ideological
self-segregation is proceeding nicely
actually it's a really good point it is
people leaving California who are more
conservative leaning going to Texas and
Florida people leaving New York for the
same reason
where does the self-segregation lead to
I just love that he says he's warning
them potentially not welcome I'm warning
you you're not welcome a decentralized
Federation of State Authority I mean I
think that's kind of what we're supposed
to lead that's where we were it's where
we came from and then what happens when
you have
it's one thing when California's a
sanctuary State and they let illegal
immigrants criminal immigrants enter
their state
but then these people who enter can now
easily access any other part of the
country
so what happens when you're Arizona
dealing with a border crisis
and then California keeps their border
open lets people come in illegally and
then very easily the cross in Arizona
okay if this hyperpolarization keeps
happening Arizona sets up a border
they set up a checkpoint and they say we
have way too many people coming in from
California that we don't know if our
citizens so we're going to do a border
checkpoint and now you've got to show
your idea if you want to get through
I you know it's reasonable it's a big
inconvenience for 99.9 of the people
going from California Arizona but it's
maybe for a weekend they could try it I
don't know that's a thing this is what I
get a big cost and not that much just
administrative cost I'm thinking putting
putting putting uh a booth
I don't I I don't think it's it's that
expensive to put a couple booths on a
few highways that go in and out of the
state
like they would like check the trunk of
every car that came by no they just stop
and say what's your business in Arizona
where are you heading and then I'm just
driving through them on the okay have a
nice day I see your ID kind of thing got
an ID so if you don't have an ID you
won't be able to do a cross-stage order
I'm not saying it's a good thing I'm
saying that's where we head that's
that's where we go if we're we're
getting to the point where
you look we've already talked about how
in some of these blue States there's
child sex change sanctuaries
there's already the fear this is what
I'm worried about some kid on tick tock
sees all these videos
Finds A Book Like This
calls the number meets a stranger on the
internet who says I'll drive you to
Washington and get you your treatment
effectively kidnapping the kid bring him
to Washington and Washington says it's
legal
now what happens if you're in Montana or
Wyoming Wyoming is the number one Trump
supporting state in the country what
happens if you're from Wyoming and
someone takes your kid and brings them
to Washington
now you've got a very very serious
border dispute because Washington said
oh that guy who kidnapped your kid
he was doing your kid a favor and then
you say I want my kid returned to me and
they say no because you're the criminal
federal government doesn't intervene
what happens
you are going to get Wyoming being like
we're going to set up checkpoints to
make sure people aren't kidnapping
children to bring them to Washington for
for uh for lewd and lascivious reasons
yeah you just gotta have the feds the
feds are supposed to they're not going
to do it that's the only the only way to
prevent these States from going rogue is
to have Federal enforcement and
oversight you need that and protect then
you're talking about stronger federal
law enforcement and we don't have that
if anything the feds will protect
Washington and the kidnapper that's so
messed up yeah even under Trump even
under Trump trump made the mistake of
thinking that these people would operate
any differently
what do you mean who uh who are these
people the the FBI
Trump trump literally thought I can't
that dude made up so many mistakes in
trusting these people over and over and
over again yeah it was like he's on
autopilot that was weird I think he just
actually had faith in the system I think
Trump thought it was busted but he could
fix it and he saw the general good in
you in the United States I think now
it's the opposite now he's like these
people are corrupt the whole thing's
gotta go
but this is my point when we're looking
at Rick Scott jokingly say socials and
commies don't come here and then the
left actually gets mad because they
actually are socialists and commies
like we're we're heading to a dark place
how would you guys Define socialist what
would make somebody a socialist public
ownership of the means of production
yeah so so yeah communism is like worker
ownership over the means of production
and then how socialism is different from
communism changes based on who you're
talking to some say that like social I
think as a general rule when you look at
how they've operated in the world
communism usually happens because of
like some Revolution or state takeover
and socialism is usually voted in but
that's not actually definitive Well they
um some some say socialism is economic
and communism is political yeah well
people say communism encompasses
everything right so even your culture
becomes Modified by it where socialism
just refers to econ but there are a
bunch of different ways people Define it
and I've heard it defined even by
official sources multiple different ways
so it's every communist state is
socialist but every socialist state is
not necessarily communist yeah yeah I
suppose so what would that be like State
ownership is communist but if it's just
state communism is is typically
characterized by
a single party controlling everything in
like an authoritarian or thorocratic
mean
gulagging people disappearing people
socialism is where the people own
everything socialism can actually
socialism is interesting because there's
like a threshold for it right
if you're looking at a spectrum you can
argue America is a capitalist country
right yeah except half of our half of
our money is taxed and goes to the
public so actually the United States is
not a capitalist economy it's a mixed
economy
at a certain point
you can call it socialist or capitalist
what's that line up to you maybe 70
percent
if 70 of your income is kept by you and
30 goes to the public that's the
threshold for being a capitalist country
anything from 70 up to 100 of the money
you keep as capitalist and then anything
in between is mixed and then 70 Taxation
and higher is socialist I don't know to
be fair it's not just about government
taxation yeah socialism is basically
like the workers own the factory
communism is like everyone owns
everything but there's actually a
military in control and they'll execute
you if you disagree
but it it can be it can be a bit uh
vague the simple thing is socialism is
basic economics the further you go
towards the public owning everything is
the further you go towards socialism the
further you go towards private ownership
the further you go towards capitalism
and capitalism is better yeah
unquestionably yeah I I think also like
just in terms of how the word is usually
understood
um communism has a much more baggage
associated with it on the cultural
question which I think is part of why
people associate it with a complete
cultural takeover and because that's
also what you saw in Communist States
like the USSR or communist China
and so people people will almost view
socialism as just sort of a moderate
form of Communism but that's not really
an accurate way of looking at it either
we have a lot of people pointing out
there already are border checkpoints
some saying when you uh you generally
stop at state borders to pay tolls
already so those could easily be
modified to stop and check your ID other
people mention that there are way
stations and agricultural checkpoints
already between states I'm saying it
becomes like
country to Country effectively Arizona
is dealing with a mass influx of illegal
immigrants taxes as well
at a certain point they might just be
like we have to control our borders but
that would be like if someone because
there'll be Vans and trucks you need to
stop the van come around out back open
the van
walks around the truck yep absolutely
that's a lot of a lot of Labor it sure
is and I'm saying it's a bad thing
though it uh whether you think it's good
or bad is not the point what matters is
if we are by if we are if we are
segregating to this degree it will
happen when covet happened they had
checkpoints new uh I think Connecticut
had checkpoints because they didn't want
New Yorkers fleeing because of the
lockdowns into Connecticut for Safe
Haven so they were like checking license
plates and stuff like that yo crazy and
who would have ever thought that would
have happened before covet right yeah to
your point now it's it's like
you know Europe used to have checkpoints
between the countries and then you get
the European Union in the Schengen Zone
but I think the U.S actually headed in
that direction because you're gonna
you're gonna have I think Wyoming and
Washington are a really good example I
think you got Idaho in between but so
maybe it'll be Idaho actually Otto's
pretty conservative spot and they're
going to get issues Wyoming is going to
be like why are you allowing these
people to take our kids through your
state and they're going to say okay and
why am I was going to be like we expect
you to cooperate with us on law
enforcement so Idaho is going to be like
we got this Corridor that goes through
goes to Montana to Washington whatever
we're gonna set checkpoints
it's I think what is it one highway it's
probably there's probably some smaller
ones I think it's one Highway up north
yeah it's one highway I'm actually
fearful of how the federal government
might try to crack down on that
um well I could just see if you have a
regime that's as far to the left as the
one that's in power now is and that
wants to push for this mutilation of
children I can imagine them saying no
you can't uh you can't tell someone
they're not able to pass through your
state in order to get their quote
unquote gender affirming care to be to
be fair there's one Federal Highway one
big it's I-90 right one Interstate but
then there there are a bunch of smaller
roads smaller State highways yes but but
to be completely honest I can count them
yeah it's not a lot I can go all the way
all the way what are we looking at up
north you mean so from if I'm if I'm
looking at just out of Washington
you can you can man it's really nice
yeah it's rugged up there there's one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten and in winter time a lot of those
three yeah ten roads so if you got to
the point where Washington act there
actually was an issue of kids being
trafficked into Washington for child sex
changes
and States like Idaho were like no way I
mean actually Let's Lose Idol as an
example relatively conservative place
they don't want their kids being brought
there so what all they need is 10
checkpoints 10. yeah yo that's 20 guys
20 guys on rotation work in a border
yeah and like I said in the winter time
a lot of those places are not even you
can't navigate them they're like
coverage so there's no way through it's
mostly it's gonna be one or two roads
they might exit to another state you'd
have to have your entire border blocked
off or covered yeah no in it's ten roads
the whole the whole border they're just
talking about the Western going going
east yes if you're in Washington it is
10 roads out of Washington you have to
go south well they said Idaho okay into
Idaho yeah yeah so Washington into Idaho
there are 10 roads thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time